me and some have a
pretty crazy pretty crazy dance that
opens the movie
uh yeah we kick it off on a pretty
strong level i know you're you're
filming in parts unknown right now so
i'm gonna give you the floor because i
know you have a huge announcement you
want to make actually the dance floor
that's what i'm going to give you i'm
going to give you a dance floor we just
wrapped magic mike three uh but we're
down here in the yucatan i'm not gonna i
can disclose what we're doing down here
in the yucatan peninsula
um but uh i'm i'm here today to announce
that uh magic mike live is coming to
miami um we've been uh we've been it's
been a long road weirdly and it
shouldn't have been a long road
like because we we sort of in the first
movie tease we gotta go we're gonna hit
miami first and then we're gonna go to
like you know we're gonna go global and
all this stuff that mcconaughey was like
you know geniusly like spewing
in the first movie um
and you know we didn't even know we were
gonna do a live show during the first
movie and then uh and then we ended up
doing it in vegas i think it was one of
our first sort of ideas after we sort of
had made this show that we all fell in
love with
we were just like we got to do like a
tour in america like that isn't a
residency in a in like a fixed place
where people have to come to it we want
to bring it to everyone you know all
over america because it's just it's
medicine it's medicine for the soul and
i don't really care it's not
it is for the ladies it is for it is for
if you like dancing and men then it's
for you as well the feeling that i
always try to tell people is like you
don't want to go take a shower
afterwards you just kind of want to fix
your makeup like a little bit like you
know like
you you just like you you go you have a
good time you feel like you got what you
wanted but like you know so i'm
wondering like what are we gonna get in
my what's the ramp up in miami you know
that's a good question because like
what's interesting about
the touring show in general is that
um so we have some of our ogs that are
have been from from vegas and then we
have our london cats and then we have
you know we had uh australia and germany
and australia just shut because of um
covid and we're gonna go back to
australia uh germany ended up shutting
but we had all great guys now but
they're all from all different places in
the world so this is going to be kind of
like this really strange i think
cataclysmic sort of a mix of like all of
our different
guys from all these different places and
i don't know it's it's going to be it's
going to be
really and everyone wants to go on the
traveling tour like like all of our best
answers when you're looking for new
dancers because you do have a good eye
like picking i mean
they're very good when you're looking
what what do you look for
look you got to be you got to have your
own steez you got to like be
you got to bring something that i've
never seen before and like you know
because they're there because there are
kids that can do stuff now that i don't
even know how they're doing what they're
doing
uh they're so good
but i would say the even more important
than the dancing because we've not hired
like some of the best dancers that i've
ever seen
because i just didn't know if they were
like a good fit for our show
like one of we do like extensive
interviews with these guys to get to
know them
what's their relationship with their mom
like what is
do they
really actually respect women like
because i think that is what our show
is just completely different and
it is a it is a categorically it's a
love letter to women your show's a love
letter to women it really really is uh
thank you for saying that because that
that is truly it's
it's made by men but like
four women but we have enlisted some of
the most beautiful like sold women to
help us like make this thing my
choreographers have been
with me since the very first movie
uh to our to our designer to like every
single person along the way we we've
we've done like i think just like a
really special job and like curating the
people that are like creating this show
truly and everyone is like a family and
we're all like-minded let's
think about and look back on on the
success and kind of the evolution of
magic mike because
you have now actually made magic mike a
brand it's a it's a complete and total
brand because you've had the movies
then you had the unscripted reality
series you've got these live shows and
now you've got a tour going on has there
been one that was like most challenging
to get off the ground over another the
very first movie weirdly like i mean
reed uh
my creative partner he wrote all the all
the magic mics and and we did uh the
live show together we kind of talked
about wanting to make a movie but we
weren't out there like killing ourselves
to try and like make this thing it was
just sort of like i had an experience
when i was 18 and 19 years old of being
in tampa in this weird little like world
and then
uh we knew we wanted to make it a movie
because we'd never seen it before and i
got to be honest the thing that was like
a labor of love was once i decided to
actually make this live show
everyone was like that's an amazing idea
because like wicked had just come you
know out like you know wicked's this
massive sort of the thing and and
travels all over the world and everybody
goes yes that's a yes we want to be a
part of that and then when it comes to
actually putting the money up everyone
was like whoa
you know go with your business model and
we were like no we've told you like
we've never done this and like we can
give you a business model but we're
because magic makes a little it's a
little different it's not just running a
a theater show yeah like it's nightclub
it's it
has you know wait staff it has um
front of the house back a house it has
like the actual show itself it has tech
i mean there's so many different moving
pieces to it
but that was the hardest thing you know
the one question that people at home
especially a lot of the ladies that come
see this show and everyone that comes to
see this show wants to know
is there a chance that channing tatum
could pop up in one of these cities on
this tour take a little bit of the stage
since we know that magic mike's last
dance is coming
uh
yeah 100 um okay
there is a there's two there's two
dances in the um in the in the lab show
that ever since the very first time that
we created it i was like uh well i'm
doing that at some point because
they're just so good they're just so
like
i don't know they're just so me and and
like allison or my my
she's like
we're both so like linked in to like
what we love and
and she even looked at me when we were
creating and she was like you're gonna
do this aren't you and i was like yep
and
uh so i mean i'm definitely i have no
idea when it's more of a time thing ten
years ago in the original you gave us
the floor hump
so what can we expect do we have another
iconic
move
in last dance because you told me you
were given a hundred on this one do we
have something that i'm gonna be like
what uh
look
they're two totally different
um
[Music]
meals if you will like they're apples
and oranges um
it's not just a dance right like there's
it's a
or a move i guess it's like a whole
dance like
i've never you've never really seen mike
give like a lap dance like you've seen
me dance on stage
but you've never seen me give like a
like a like an intimate straight up
one-on-one
lap dance
um so like that's definitely gonna be in
in the third one
uh yeah me and salma have a
pretty crazy pretty crazy dance that
opens the movie
uh yeah we kick it off uh on a pretty
strong level and then and then at the
end um i might do a version of uh of the
water dance in the in the show so it's
uh it's it
yeah
everybody like there's a splash zone in
the in the in the movie uh so like it's
it's a it's it's a for real thing p
island um you know zoe of course said
that you were her first choice for this
film so why were you shocked that you
were asked to play this part when you
were her first choice for the film i
definitely don't play any one that i've
ever played before in this in this movie
okay um i think
people call me for very specific things
you know very like
dear johnny kind of like nicholas sparks
or like uh yeah you know the dummy in
the movie that you know is running
around and like being kind of silly and
and uh maybe not the smartest guy or to
dance or to do action you know and this
is just a completely categorically
different thing and it was it was
it was one like really awesome to like
to be thought of in that way that i
could do that and then also you know a
very specific
point of hers was just like look i i
really know that she really made or saw
me i guess and like that i
i really do i i've
i was raised by women i i
i
yes i guess i'm a feminist but i i know
that word
puts some people off but i just believe
that everybody is exactly the same on
and deserves the same
um
treatment and and things in this world
and and like
i don't know i just it's really simple
for me i don't need to like
do the whole
uh
academic point of view on it all just
like you know my mom and my sister
there's nobody in the world that i that
i love more than them and that i respect
more than them
and i and that was kind of what her
point was she was just like that's why
you kind of have to play this part can
you tell me who you play
i play a character called slater king
yes it's it's hard to i i i will be
giving things away if i tell you exactly
who he is because once it once it like
sort of comes out i'm a very very
successful um
[Music]
got a lot of money uh yeah i don't know
if i get if i start going down the road
of telling you
who
the amalgamation of this person is it'll
sort of tip my hand uh but it's i i can
tell you it's it's incredible
i'm in awe she's doing better than reed
and i did on on our first movie with dog
i mean
geez we barely survived our first movie
and and um and she's just killing it and
we're we're here and and we're we're all
and it's like a weird little like summer
camp
where we're in this like beautiful
hacienda in the yucatan
and uh and we're we're doing some really
really cool stuff and it's super
stylized and and and yet really fun but
has like a very deep and um
i think a shocking sort of uh message at
some point i was going to ask what made
her the perfect person to do this but i
think you just said it she saw you she
saw who you are yeah no she uh she
definitely she's got a weird gift for
that uh she sees right through a lot of
people's stuff and really kind of just
who they are to her is really simple
like and she's one of the more
intentional people i've ever met in my
life
[Music]
you